vous
[Musique]
on les a vus assoiffés en pleine
canicule
abreuvés par des pompiers ou encore des
passants attentionné mais ces
comportements sont inhabituelles pour
les poêles 1
[Musique]
jusqu'à récemment on croyait qu'en
dehors de circonstances exceptionnelles
ces marsupiaux buvait peu voire pas du
tout on pensait qu'il se contentait de
l'eau contenue dans les jeunes feuilles
d'eucalyptus dont ils se nourrissent
or des observations rapportées par une
équipe de l'université de saint-denis
montrent qu'ils ont en réalité une
manière bien à eux de se désaltérer en
laissant les arbres
valentina mail a analysé 46 occasions
des koalas ont été vus en train de
s'abreuver de cette façon pendant ou peu
de temps après la pluie ce comportement
étonnant a été observée dans le sud est
de l'australie près de vérone où le
climat est tempéré mais aussi dans des
zones chaudes et sèches de la région des
auteurs de l'étude en conclut que les
koala privilégie cette manière de boire
il préfère les corses ruisselante aux
flaques d'eau par exemple peu importe la
température la saison où l'abondance des
précipitations me
il semble aussi choisir leur perchoir
avec soin pour maximiser l'eau qui
peuvent récolter
un comportement qui concorde avec le
mode de vie arboricole des koalas
[Musique]
mais les spécialistes s'inquiètent
si ces animaux emblématiques de
l'australie compte sur la pluie pour
s'hydrater et changement climatique
pourrait leur être néfaste
les précipitations se raréfient dans
plusieurs régions du pays qui
enregistrent des records de chaleur et
de sécheresse mais koala pourrait
bientôt mourir de soif